[Music]
for many people decluttering is a
popular way to mark the beginning of a
new year that's me but instead of
tossing or donating unwanted items a
growing number of americans are first
offering them to their neighbors for
free it's part of the buy nothing
project and the membership is exploding
nationwide janet chamlion went to the
woodlands texas to find out how this
movement is offering far more than just
giveaways
jordan cheatham is stopping at a
neighbor's home to drop off a fondue pot
she's never used
the mom of three found a taker for it on
the local buy nothing facebook group she
helps run last six months what have you
given
clothes shoes books
dishes let me see a couple pieces of
furniture
people post photos of what they're
giving away on a neighborhood buy
nothing facebook group or through the
buy nothing app earrings propane it runs
the gamut really you will find it all
here members can also ask for something
they need everything is donated with no
strings attached trading bartering
buying or selling not allowed friends
lisa clark and rebecca rockefeller
started the buy nothing movement in
2013. i think we originally were
thinking okay
we can all offer up what we'd like to
give in this hyper local gift economy
and
try to solve that question of do we have
too much in our homes can we share our
bounty
they didn't realize then what's apparent
now it's about more than decluttering an
economic need
i have to say in the last year and a
half i've made so many probably lasting
friendships just from this group and
that's the point of the group in the
soul is basically learning to you know
know who your neighbors are helping each
other and becoming a true community
jordan has received things like this
lamp a dresser art for her wall these
chairs and a table
but perhaps the most important gifts
came when her daughter was born in
october 2020 jordan had an emergency
c-section she posted a desperate plea in
her buy nothing group formula question
mark baby is not doing well on breast
milk the response overwhelmed her when i
got home my front porch and inside was
full of formula i had like two or three
months worth of supply from at least 15
people it really shows that you know
you're never alone it's okay to ask for
something and you know be loved on by
people
buy nothing has spread to almost 7 000
communities across more than 40
countries the pandemic fueled a spike in
membership more than a million and a
half people joined and the number taking
part in buying nothing groups now tops 5
million worldwide are the by nothing
groups on the internet one of the last
kind corners sometimes it feels like
that to me and i think because in a by
nothing community you you know that
you're speaking literally to your
neighbors with record inflation and the
stresses of the pandemic by nothing
became for some a financial and
emotional lifeline
it really brings joy to others but
honestly brings more joy to yourself
helping others and you know it's good to
receive too and build a community it is
really worth doing for cbs morning's
janet chamleon the woodlands texas
it feels great it feels great to give
people things uh and also particularly
with kids stuff yeah wear it like two
times like a winter coat yeah it's great
to just hand it pass it on down the line
giving is a love language that everybody
is fluent yeah yeah we can all speak it
you're so right about that nate i like
the my favorite line the piece where she
says it can show that you're never alone
no matter what you were going through
and how isolated you feel right there's
somebody that's feeling that that's
right it's a good reminder of that
that's true janet thank you